all right well in jake's absence we're
deciding to play him a little song he's
on vacation
probably swimming and in his honor we'll
sing him under the sea hey go three two
one go
[Music]
you dream about going
[Music]
my dreams my sorrows they are under
that's it that's the beat poetry version
of under the scene
yeah all right yeah so anyways back to
business
that was very cultural yeah now i mean
that's the thing it's like
there are certain songs that have
melodies that are so strong that even if
you play the wrong notes they kind of
sound like the song
yeah that's where you can recognize it
at least yeah pretty much every song
pretty much every song if you listen to
it enough
yeah so jake's not here so it's just us
in this room nor banjo
we're not wearing headphones we're just
gonna have a good old time talking about
things
uh we maybe we should talk about nick's
dad and how cool he is
first off he'll never live up to his
awesomeness
he does kick flips he does he does
stunts
nick you're the stronger he's in the
tune channel you're just as cool
oh man stays up late
9 30. so nick's dad uh
used to work for ilm um and he's worked
for a whole bunch of other
like cool companies and like when nick's
mentioned that us to us in the past
we're like that's neat
uh and then he's like he's coming from
vfx arts reaction like okay
and then he came in for a vfx react and
that's when he realized like oh he
worked at ilm
from like the mid-90s to the early 2000s
which is like the heyday of ilm
and he's like oh yeah he's the one who
made the mummy
like as in he designed the mummy
and here's his drawings of the mummy and
it's like
oh oh your dad's really legit i'm really
glad you guys saved that reaction
for when we were rolling the cameras too
because it was a good one
yeah and like things like uh you know
designing like the uh the beach mat
painting for like saying private ryan
and like explaining about how he did the
historical research there and it's like
he holds up like this print out he has
like oh i did this in photoshop and then
you look at the actual shot from the
movie and like half the elements are
just the photoshop elements
put into like that frame and you're like
wow he basically made that shot too
and like just the list went on of all
these things that he worked on and like
holding like the original pencil
storyboards for like the beginning of
the mummy in my hands was pretty neat
it's like man this is actually like some
legitimate film history and
you know your dad was talking to steven
spielberg like working out details
and all that kind of stuff i guess i uh
i took that for granted growing up
just like literally growing up in that
like small office
in uh san rafael california it was
called kerner optical they had to name
it
they gave it a moniker so that crazy
fans oh star wars won't like find ilm
and like try to steal all the models huh
but oh
yeah man that's funny that must have
been wait do you know anything about
that
is that a thing well i mean the fan base
of star wars has always been a little
bit crazy i think
so lucas has always been a very like
just quiet like to himself dude
and you know he lived in the bay area
in the north bay north of san francisco
so
he you know decided i think we went into
this a bit in the episode
he decided to move ilm up to the bay so
it was in his backyard
and also because it was away from all
the paparazzi and all most of those fans
that were
maybe willing to like sneak onto the
premises
and you know um but i'm sure there were
probably
instances where that happened because
star wars was huge
so and um
i mean it was probably a good thing
because like i remember
in my dad would bring back sometimes
things he'd pull out from the dumpsters
behind the model shop
and they would be like miscasts of like
models like big spaceships or like uh
for instance the anubis statues from the
mummy oh yeah they'd be like perfectly
cast except for one little bubble in the
foot
and they'd be like oh we gotta throw
that away so there was some good
dumpster
dumpster diving you know opportunities
there that i'm sure they didn't want to
like
let people in on because it could give
away things about the movies or i don't
know
but yeah you probably don't make that
choice to like
make covert names for all your offices
until
you have to yeah probably i wonder when
we're gonna have to get there
and that's crazy i have this aspiration
to
have an art collection of like pieces
from films not just like oh here's a
prop but like
here's like a matte painting that was
used in this iconic shot or here's like
a storyboard for this iconic sequence
and i feel like the only way to actually
assemble that stuff is like know the
people that
made them like you can't just go out and
buy it from like a collector necessarily
yeah man well i mean i'm sure if we uh
petitioned him he might be able to hook
it up with something we could frame and
put on the office
having some stuff framed in corridor
would be pretty sweet um
because i mean even if they're prints
like they only exist on his
hard drive or whatever so i mean it's
still maybe we could even get some
original storyboards
yeah um no it was it was really cool
having him on i wasn't sure like if he'd
be good on camera
he was good he was great he clearly has
watched a lot of episodes yeah
and i mean he's i mean he's just a
natural vfx nerd too
so i think this these so we ended up
actually today
dean and chase were like we we can't cut
all this stuff because
by the way we shot it was our longest
ever shoot longest ever vfx artist
reaction
yeah yeah it was it was over a day 13
hours
yeah well it's for two episodes it was
for two episodes yes
still yeah so we had to do this hbo uh
integration which is a whole episode
and we decided to film it that day as
well uh because he was
he's an ex hbo employee too so we're
like yeah that works
so we shot all thursday uh
mostly talking about ilm stuff most of
the day and then we shot a little bit
more on friday so
it's a record for us but we're gonna
split up the episodes now we're gonna do
just a mummy focused episode
and then we're gonna do one with private
ryan mummy returns talk about the
scorpion king shot the worst
shot and then uh oh you guys put him in
the hot seat
oh yeah yeah i mean ren was like so
why does this shot
no he's uh he's heard it before so
he's heard it before yeah i mean that
shot got panned i think when it came out
so i don't want to harp more on it but i
think he gave a pretty good explanation
of like
where things went wrong in that process
and you know
took kind of uh i guess credit for it
as a collective you know it wasn't one
person but
yeah i think it's also worth like
remembering that like stuff like that
like it's not that big of a deal like
it's not a big deal if there's a bad vfx
shot in a movie
like we like to laugh ahead and point it
out because it's ilm
and everything they do is always so good
like to have one little flaw that's like
oh they're human like us
like so what if it's a bad effect shot
you know they're movies they're for fun
you know it's like i think it's easy
some people can get caught up in
taking it too seriously when it's like
yeah it's also not like comedically bad
either
like there's comedically bad effects in
like like the street fighter movie is a
great example
like all the that's like that's funny
because of how bad that is i actually
saw a comment for that
on a vfx artist react we should look at
that i think didn't we we did actually
oh did we okay
yeah not the original c5 but the one
from 2009 or something yeah that one was
pretty nasty yeah
we're just like straight up like
mistakes and rotoscopes and stuff like
that
did your dad ever see that episode like
we fixed the worst vfx shot
was he like oh yeah you're like okay
you know that was kind of an awkward one
to explain to him like the title
i'm like because i mean he watches the
channel so they see all the videos we
really make and
that was a what three years ago no
almost something like that yeah
geez time flies um but
yeah i mean you know he
wasn't angry or anything i think by
there's enough time that's gone past
that they've all been able to kind of
you know cringe that one out you know
sometimes you gotta cringe it
out at night yeah yeah
um but i mean he
you know that was basically a case of
the director
wanting something very specific and then
the vfx team was like oh you don't quite
have the technology
and they had to do it anyway so
i mean they give it a go but that's
there's a lot of ambition yeah yeah
that's
kind of how it usually goes yes exactly
yeah that's how you make great things
and if you missed mark oh well i mean we
have plenty of shots that have bad vfx
on our channel like
yeah we have tons about it a lot of
people think because we do vfx rs react
that all our effects need to be flawless
so it's like no not really
time you know yeah definitely
one cool thing that you guys can look
forward to in that episode whenever it
comes out we don't really have
a time slot for that to come out but he
provided us with a bunch of the
alternate concept illustration for the
scorpion king and some of them are like
cool some of them are kind of funny so
we'll be showing a lot of that stuff
yeah that's cool um you know there's a
whole team of people drawing that guy
in every possible variation um and a lot
of them look
i think i think better but you know yeah
it's not the rock i'm surprised like
what else are you gonna do it's like a
dude on a scorpion like
what's the other version of that i mean
some of them look like straight up like
i know this isn't egyptian but like one
of them looks like straight you took
like jafar's face from
aladdin and like put him on like a more
like insect-like scorpion
so there's some really weird like
hybrids going on
yeah the one they use is very literal
it's literally a scorpion.obj
and then they chop it and they put the
rock on there a little crown on the top
rock that object with a crown
he's a king but
no it's yeah i think we got a lot of
good stuff
so and we've never looked at the art
direction side of the effects before
we often critique like the final thing
the 3d models
but i would hope that there's still as
much thought put into it
as there was back in the 90s so
yeah yeah well i mean it's a different
process like we've never
i mean well not never but we've rarely
drawn a shot before we made it usually
it's like you get the footage and you're
just like
yeah you just start playing with it
right there in the moment
to build things out so that was i guess
one of the reasons
why ilm was like at the top of their
game because they were a one-stop shop
they had artists
all in-house that could literally go
down the hall and talk to the
creature 3d artists and modelers
and the model shop as well coolest job
in the world by the way you get to make
models all day
yeah dude oh my gosh i mean the model
shop basically single-handedly went on
to like be the mythbusters yes
essentially yeah it was grant um
imahara rest in peace uh tori
jamie and adam were some of the main
guys there and there's a bunch of old
school dudes too
but they were like the the
contemporaries
then of yeah the whole art department so
dude i remember as a kid just going
through
and being like like what the [ __ ]
is this place because it was just like
there were spaceships everywhere
dragons monsters um and it had that like
epoxy smell and paint
epoxy smell literally just in like this
warehouse
so it was it was crazy man yeah so
yeah really cool we're gonna be taking a
yeah we're gonna be taking a little walk
down memory lane and some
cinematic history and these episodes
coming up i'm surprised netflix doesn't
do any of this kind of stuff
or anybody for that matter like
commentary tracks why not
i mean i guess they're here and there on
netflix but like i'm really surprised
it's not more of a thing it's such like
an
easy thing to produce yeah to like have
some history and the stuff you make well
netflix is doing it here and there it's
just that they're so
like broad you know that like
they're not for instance like the one
they released well they thankfully
released like a vfx breakdown for army
of the dead but like
i was trying to do research for that and
like the only stuff they have out other
than
the breakdown is just like a bunch of
real light general stuff that
never there's no like actual information
in there you know it's just marketing
it's marketing basically their 3d
scanning rig for the zombies how sick is
that though
they have like the grip pushing this
like cart around
they also used accent suits that was
pretty cool to learn so they get kind of
in depth
not quite yeah like the breakdown they
release is like the most
robust vfx breakdown i've seen of any
movie like
other than like the marvel stuff lately
yeah
it was cool to see that though maybe
maybe they'll start doing more of that
stuff
if it actually gets views yeah i mean
that's the thing it's well if
this show you know this vfx artists
react show it's like i think it's just
it
shows that like you don't have to be
into filmmaking
to enjoy like seeing the process break
down because ultimately you're just
looking at cool images and go hey how
did how was that made
you know and it's it's it's interesting
so yeah the disney documentary was
pretty cool
which was like just all the different
animations like they broke down just how
like
finding nemo and toy story and they did
it in a timeline
as well that's the song disney plus yeah
i watch it on
netflix yeah really good really in depth
you really just see kind of how they
structured you know like the different
warehouses and when they all started
collabing and they were like halfway
through toy story two and then they were
like oh we hate it and they had to redo
it but they were still in the same
timeline and
it was crazy the technology they were
using do you have a great story about i
think it was toy story 2 where
they accidentally wiped the master off
their server maybe that's what maybe
that's what it was
maybe somebody had brought it home to
like show their kid
and they like it's like don't lose that
hard drive that's the entire movie right
now
on that hard drive wow yeah
that's that's probably good on a hard
drive
yeah dude i went back and watched toy
story 1
and i watched shrek 1 recently and
we should look at that on on uh
animators react because there's some
crude stuff there
oh yeah like in shrek there's straight
up a scene where like there's like
he's in his little bog hut and there's
like some shadows from trees being
reflected
and they're straight up like tiled like
pixeled like
uh like in a video game essentially and
like
that's stuff you didn't even realize but
now it's like oh my gosh this is like
oh yeah the first toy story is the same
way there's like a ton of shots very
frequently
where you see like either super janky
animation for characters where you're
like it's like whoa
that that looks like you know student
film
student like animation kind of like
level stuff and
they they don't shy away from showing
close-ups of like
really low-res textures as well i've
noticed
i mean i've come back to this a lot but
i've seen the movie a lot of times
and so there's like a ton of details
like that you watch through and you're
like ugh like that's like the lowest res
picture for this like ground and usually
it's it's it's pretty wild i mean
granted you know 25 years ago
but you know it's it's interesting
well we were just talking about this the
other day i forget who it was with but
we're wondering aloud if there's maybe
someone can comment below
is there like a name for the effect of
like seeing something
and it's novel and it looks great and
then like 10 years later you look back
and you're like oh that looks like
absolute crap it's probably like yeah
that's like the ultimate there's a
german word for this yeah yeah there
must be some german guy who in the 20s
you know theorized about this yeah yeah
i i agree
leave a comment below if you know the
theory uh because that happens all over
the place
it's not even just like movies it's just
like even experiences
like i remember i was like oh yeah i was
like up in the up
michigan i went to college up there i
was like oh there's this great
restaurant
so great we're gonna love it we're gonna
we're gonna go because i went there in
college
we had the best time here and i go back
there with
you know my wife and my sister and we
walk in it's just like
it smells like garbage and we look
around like it looks exactly the same
and they're playing like bad music and
it's just like
this this like this is nice
like we immediately turn away and walk
out but it's like the same exact effect
you know
i almost remembered like the mandela
effect or something like you like the
sworn
something was the way it was yeah and
then you like misremembered it nope it
wasn't
i had that for this restaurant called
fire and ice have you ever heard of that
place no you probably just like that
because of the cool names
you're like to meet me at fire and
knight in the
the rear table
i remember like when i was like 10 we
went on a trip to boston to visit family
and there's like this restaurant
called fire nice and like we went there
and like it was this restaurant where
you like serve yourself and they cook it
on a big hibachi
like behind the counter and it was like
the coolest thing as a 10 year old
you're like yeah dude i get to choose my
ingredients give me all those beans give
me all this meat all the bees
and i remember always like when i was a
kid i'd be like i'd look up where fire
and ice was because i wanted to go back
it was a chain restaurant or was it just
one it was a chain
it was a chain there were some other
ones and i finally i forget where
i found a restaurant that did the same
kind of thing
it wasn't a fire nice but i was like
several years older more refined and
golden corral kind of does it yeah maybe
it was a golden corral
golden corral the whole time yeah
dang i've been old old at heart since i
was 10.
but it just was not the same experience
it was just like oh this is kind of
gross it's just like a bunch of beans
it's not the same experience that's
funny yeah we often
remember things much more intensely i
think
but yeah when i was up in minnesota two
weeks ago
uh we were driving up to this wedding
and we happened to
go through the town uh that i i guess
grew up in when i from when i was born
when i was age five i grew up in the
town of rice minnesota
which is a town of 400 people um and we
were driving through it and i was like
ivy we should see if we can see my old
house
because i haven't been back to my old
house there since i left it when i was
five years old
and so i drove there from memory
i managed to find the house and i was
like you drive down the driveway
and i was like they're gonna think i'm
weird there's a really long driveway
so like you have to very intentionally
be going to the house just do it i'm
like alright
so i drove down and sure enough one of
the owners of the house is out there
gardening
and she's like hey how's it going like
hey uh i used to live here actually i
just uh
showed my wife we were on tours like oh
that's cool what's your name i'm like oh
it's nico perringer and she's like oh
yeah yeah
yeah we bought it from your dad from 30
years ago and it's like
whoa okay so you guys haven't left yet
it's like no he's like
do you want to have a tour i was like
yes and so i got to tour
my old childhood house that i haven't
been back to in 30 years and
it's one of those things where it's like
you know it leaves an impression on you
and that like
your mental vision of like houses is
always that house that you kind of grew
up in
um and it was really cool walking back
through it and like they hadn't changed
very much of it
it's just the whole thing is a little
bit smaller than i remembered
because i was a lot smaller a little
smaller
yeah but that was really cool that's
trippy
yeah that's really trippy it's one of
those things that you talk about where
it's like yeah
it's your memory of it's one thing and i
was happy that my memory of it wasn't
that far off from what it actually was
like
this beautiful backyard it's really nice
out
but yeah i was a little bit smaller than
i remember it
being yeah it's strong i was hoping that
the same thing was going to happen to me
and
i was in san francisco this weekend and
i went to go visit my
great grandmother's she owned a
three-story flat in the heart of san
francisco
and so i went back knit all they did was
just change the color of it but i
remembered like the steps going up
and i was just hoping that someone would
be coming out and i'd be like
please like please let me go inside of
it it'd be so cool because they're
they're so much bigger than they think
you know all the houses in san francisco
yeah
and they look like they're small but
they go back so far
and they usually have they have gardens
in the back
there's so much i haven't been there in
like over 10 years now
but i definitely would have so you
weren't able to actually get inside
no no one walked in or out
i still remember my the smell of my
grandma's flat in san francisco
where my dad grew up and she lived her
whole life
what area do you remember it was in
north beach it was on uh
chestnut street um i forgot the address
yeah
but yeah it had like this like mix of
like mildew and cigarette smell
nice and it was just like this really
old building but yeah it had like this
huge it went back
yeah they're huge crazy you know sam's a
san francisco baby too yep yeah this is
funny no we're talking about like
well i too yeah
2015 was the last time i was there but i
went past my childhood home
and that was a san francisco where i
mostly grew up until i was like six
what did it smell like what did it smell
like i mean i didn't go inside
unfortunately
but a lot of crazy memories there wow
yeah just
wilding out crazy childhood memories no
i mean well like my biggest memories
like are like kind of bad ones
well like all sorts of stuff like
there's a park right across the street
from the place it was like a rec center
with like a big
you know baseball soccer field kind of
thing which is nice but like
my two main memories three main memories
of it
we're going there with my tricycle and
some kids stealing it my mom chasing
them
the second of which was these crazy
people like drifting their car through
the grass and shredding it up
and like kicking up dirt everywhere and
just like doing donuts
uh and then the third one was uh there
was like riots that were happening i
think this was like the rodney king
riots that and
yeah basically the whole street and park
was stormed and cars were smashed and
broken into and uh san francisco
has always been and then there's an
earthquake in 89
it was like my first memory like cutting
my feet up in glass and stuff and having
to wear my dad's cowboy boots
yeah it's like those probably couldn't
wait to move those are the main ones
that came to mind yeah i know i know
like there's there's good ones that
happen
inside the house but like those are like
the big ones wow
yeah my friends are like we're leaving
the city yeah yeah and they were
we're leaving and so then we moved to
minnesota yeah wow
that's like stark there's definitely a
lot of like glass everywhere because
everyone's windows are just getting
shattered yeah like we walked the golden
gate bridge
maybe took us like an hour and we walked
back and we see this family crying in
the
parking lot and we're like oh i wonder
if like they're visiting like someone
died or something
and then we just keep going and then
their whole window was smashed and like
you could tell like all the kids stuff
got stolen it was a minivan and i was
like oh my
like our car was parked right next to
theirs we could have easily
well luckily we didn't keep anything in
our car just because we know san
francisco but you know they actually
just passed the law
in san francisco you cannot like arrest
or incarcerate someone for stealing
more under 900 worth of stuff what about
that so
there's literally videos of getting
taken of people just putting stuff in
bags and just
walking yeah they go into cvs and then
they fill up a bag and then they leave
yeah oh geez
that's the word
if they're doing that then maybe like
windows would stop getting smashed
because it's like they're getting their
groceries so i don't i don't know
we'll see if it helps but yeah i don't
think that's gonna address the income
inequality
anything under 900 is free
yeah there we go no stimulus checks
needed
no like uv eyes needed there we go
yeah right yeah i want some new air pods
some new shoes yeah yeah and i need some
hair conditioner
yeah something new air conditioning yeah
you're walking into the guitar center
and like 8.99
i'm good does that include sales tax or
no yeah yeah
is it 900 with or without sales tax
because that's what i'm trying to figure
out and they're like coupons so i would
have walked like what if it's like 950
bucks i have a coupon for 20
off no no no it's not with sales tax
because that's charged by the government
so the
so yeah it's retail value it's msrp
[Laughter]
shall we go oh man
oh boy what a crazy law sf is kind of a
crazy place now
i yeah i've visited a couple times in
the last couple of years
and it's completely different i mean i'm
sure you remember it was
and you probably remember too it was
like just a normal city
working class people like just living
their lives and now it's just like tech
central
and it is well it's kind of sad to be
honest
yeah but i i didn't notice i mean the
last time i was there was like with you
in like 2016 or something remember for
uh ea
yeah you went to ea to play something
for battlefront yes
you're right that was that was a quick
little trip we did yeah i was like yeah
i think i think the last time i was up
there
yeah we only we were just in the city
though for like a night
yeah it was dark we went to like this
like this like medieval
tavern i know like with like some
taxidermy
i was like nick we have like three free
hours let's go to a crazy like belgian
restaurant
because i was like hot off oh this was
2017 oh yeah we went to the belgian
restaurant we went to the belgian
restaurant because i was like i was
craving like belgian
uh beef stew yeah
as one does yeah and some ale some some
yeah and then we went to like this other
weirdly enough another medieval
bar thing and then oh yeah that was
weird
yeah it was kind of cool is the place
that had like the lord of the rings door
that's what i call it it's the half
doors where you kind of have one
door open and then it becomes a counter
right oh it's like a saloon or something
it's kind of a saloon yeah sf
yeah gorgeous it is gorgeous i
honestly i was up there and i was like i
don't want to move here
i'd have to live on the street but i
mean 900 dollars
but i could get my groceries every day
yeah
is there a limit on that is it like a
day a week
just once a week yeah i think it's until
they forget
how much you've stolen previously and
then it refreshes
[Laughter]
oh man well i guess everywhere's kind of
turning expensive now but
everywhere is turning expensive but it's
not like
san francisco is unique a unique bird in
that you know everyone's been
complaining about for
like san francisco for like 20 or 30
years already yeah
well you also i mean you have silicon
valley and
i believe a lot of people in the tech
industry would
see themselves as being altruistic
good-natured people
which oh they probably are going to deep
cut this isn't a deep cut no no
this is not a judgment thing it's not
just things like they're all nihilists
i'm
just saying that like but when you have
an industry that's
pumping everyone full of money but other
industries aren't the same way you end
up with
yeah harsh inequality and
you know i i don't know how much people
are volunteering to
to try to fix it i mean there's the uh
what's the term for this
the pygmalion effect
i guess the pigment the classic
big million effect what is that
pygmalion effect is that people aspire
to
uh fulfill your expectations so if you
expect more from somebody they will
perform better
and they do this test with like a
classroom of students and they told this
teacher like
in that kid over there they're actually
really good achiever um so
you know you'll have a good time with
them and they would do that with random
kids it is called the pygmalion effect
it's a phenomenon where high
expectations lead to improved
performance
and so they would tell teachers like you
know have high expectations for certain
kids at random
and the kid would actually perform
better at the end of the year uh
and i look at our society and i see like
you know how we think about politicians
or police or all that kind of stuff i'm
like boy we have the exact opposite of
that going on right now like we all
expect the worst from our politicians so
why the heck would anybody ever give a
[ __ ]
you know it's like if maybe we expected
the best from people instead maybe
they'd give us their best
but if you're going to treat someone
like [ __ ] and say that they're a bag of
dicks or whatever like they're gonna be
like well
[ __ ] you i'm not gonna try sorry this is
just a bunch of profanity coming in my
mouth good luck censoring all this
christians but that really stands out to
me it's like
you know i think uh you gotta expect the
best from people in order to get the
best from people
and if you're not expecting the best
from people and you start
changing that point of view to be a
really negative one you do hold power in
that point
of view and you should catch yourself
before it gets too deep
so yeah wow well i yeah i mean
sf i don't hold any resentment for those
people i guess who are driving
no no no no no no i'm talking about like
you know
the expectations of like the politicians
to fix it with everybody i see
exposing the world yeah not that it's
necessarily the politicians
like problem to fix either like it's a
shared responsibility by everybody
it's easy to pass the buck i mean what
are you gonna do say hey if you have
more than this much money you can't move
to san francisco
it's it's kind of a hard it's really
tricky yeah
yeah it's uh but i mean hey for those
homeowners who still have their property
i'm sure they're
happy enough because yeah values have
gone up so much
but i will say owning a home for the
past year has definitely shifted my
perspective of money a little bit
because like the house has gone up in
value but
you know i've the house got in value
like every other house in emily has
um but it's not like i actually have any
more money if i were to sell it because
i can only buy the same house you know
my my dollars aren't worth anything more
it's just worth more dollars and you're
like oh
that's inflation you know
it's the house the housing supply
you know it's the same as it was last
year it's the same as was the year
before and granted right now
like people who are going to get a house
in 2020 but didn't because of the
pandemic like now you have them stacked
on top of the people that just are
naturally looking for houses in 2021
and there's also a lot of talk of
recession in 2019 so people kind of held
off then so you also just have like
a backlog of people that were looking to
get houses like that will sort itself
out in time
um but yeah just you know seeing
seeing how a house goes up in value and
just like that's not a reflection of
the value of the house it's a reflection
of the power of the dollar to some
extent
i mean it's a complicated network too
but also things like
you know even owning a house is not
really about the price of the house it's
about your monthly payment
in a way it's about your mortgage uh
which is basically just rent
because at the end of the day you don't
own a house the house outlives you
right you know that my house has had how
many families go through it you know
we're just a caretaker for the five 10
15 years that you're there
and then you pass it off to somebody
else and ideally you've done a good job
and you're rewarded with getting your
deposit back your safety deposit which
happens to be
a lot more than it would be for an
apartment but it's kind of the same
concept
i wish we could all just agree to like
instead of having these perpetual
mortgages that never get paid off and we
just keep handing the debt off to more
people like
let's just make houses like 300 bucks
like let's just lower that for everybody
and then we can actually just buy it and
sell it it would be the same thing but
you know the government made you know
the dollar stimulus last year with a
pandemic to try to keep us from having
a recession and a depression which we
had with a little bit of but like
when when mortgage rates stepped down to
be like super cheap it's like
for the exact same monthly payment i can
now buy a house that's 20
more expensive so what changed
like not a lot it's like it's it's my
monthly payment's the same because it's
not about how expensive the house is
it's about what your monthly payment is
you know your monthly payments the same
and you can buy more house suddenly it's
like way more people
are either looking for more houses or
all the prices in the houses just go up
you know so that the same people can
afford the same houses
it's just that you know the numbers have
switched to like compensate for the
other numbers switching
and at the end of the day it's like your
dollar is not worth the same amount of a
dollar anymore
it's it's all over the place so it's
been weird watching all that
like from the perspective of like real
estate and uh
yeah the real estate perspective that's
why people listen to this podcast right
you should rename it
sorry guys you just everybody listen to
this just to hear what's on our mind
at the time of the podcast and we just
hope that whatever mind is interesting
yeah
do you have any good like land picks
what are your top five land picks
yeah yeah i mean you've been the longest
homeowner here how about you
what land picks yeah
uh land with grass is uh on a downward
trend right now you don't get those
mineral rights you don't get those
lumber rights
yeah mineral lumber rights are on the
rise
what's the best kept secret secret about
swamps
uh how deep they truly are
when does the swamp become a trench
that's what i'm wondering swamp becomes
a trench oh geez
you have to get this water out of it i
don't know
out of joke territory i'm actually
wondering it's it's
i don't know uh my friend top five real
estate biomes
right now it's tundra tyga um
what is it desert no not deserts
not no not the 120 degree heat right now
worst places to spawn every morning
first place to spawn
he spawned in a hill biome everywhere
i'm gonna spawn in a hill biome every
day
yeah best nash codes to spawn into yeah
i uh i kind of had a pipe dream like
last month
of like you know because i've been
looking at moving
and everywhere i was looking at was like
oh yeah you're gonna be paying
essentially two grand of rent
so i was like okay i'm gonna maybe look
into potentially
pooling with someone else and buying a
place and then instead of paying into
nothing
paying a mortgage and i i called some
real estate agents and like
just kind of like sobered me up real
quick because like right now in la
the real estate market is just so insane
it's so
crazy my neighbor sold his house uh
and to to like just someone random
like just without a realtor it was just
like probably put up a sign up front
like four seconds he was like he's like
hey does anyone want oh
yeah okay
honestly yeah yeah it's just
it's kind of uh so i don't know you
basically see what happens
like the only way to guarantee you're
going to get a house in l.a right now is
if you
go to the house you want to buy and sit
outside until the for sale sign comes up
up there yeah you literally have to camp
spot inside the house
it might be up to a few months to a year
but yeah yeah
i will say if you it's not a bad idea to
buy a place
even with it being crazy just it's a
good time to just
start looking and like follow the trends
like
look at houses for about three or four
months two or a couple
this will settle down a little bit
probably settle next year yeah prices
aren't going to go down but they will
not climb as fast and the crazy demand
will probably
chill just a little bit there always be
some that crazy demand but
it's really just a numbers game of like
you gotta take a lot of shots for one to
hit i mean that's what i had to do
you know um but having perspective on it
like
it's because you want you want to be
looking for a couple months and like
once you've done that and you have an
idea of what to see in different houses
and what the process is like and you've
done a couple bids even if you didn't
get them
like that really helps once it becomes
time to be like okay
this house i actually really really
really really truly want and then you
want to go for it for real
having some that experience behind you
helps definitely
i got a lot to learn that's much better
than the rental game
yeah but uh yeah it's kind of cool
though to like at least imagine yourself
like oh yeah i could actually
be not just pissing my money away every
month
yeah i mean yeah so we'll see what
happens
yeah we'll see what happens i wish you
could like lease a place like how you
lose a car
oh yeah and then you can like at the end
of your lease like i'll buy it like
i'm just there are renters that do that
but they probably won't do it in l.a
yeah that makes sense
i'll probably just buy in florida first
or something i mean
i'll probably do that when i move like
you can rent it
for a year too then i'll sell it to you
just got to make sure yeah you're made
of the right stuff
just gonna make sure yeah watch you
through the cameras
[Laughter]
make sure you don't nick the walls too
much cameras
every time they're walking it's just
like sam
super loud camera
you never oil you can constantly hear
focusing
yeah so i went to omega mart
this past weekend uh some of you might
know of it um
so this is like art collective called
meow wolf and they have like this
like art installation museum place thing
experiential thing and i think it's
uh new mexico um
they all got together and puts them
together in las vegas
so it's in this place called area 15.
and part of this place of area 15 is
omegamart and you may have seen some ads
for it online or some things popping up
and it's like a alternate reality
grocery store
it's very like a it's very like aperture
science
black mesa kind of stuff with a little
bit of tim and eric mixed in
um i think the phone was ringing my
mom's calling me
[Music]
um
um and it's really cool like so they
have all these like products in the
front that are like really goofy
like there's this cereal that's like
simply
not spiders it's just like a bunch of
shredded wheat and like they're talking
about
there's no spiders in it that's all the
markings but now there's no spiders in
the cereal
or uh you know i got i got uh jake a
present if
jake listens to the podcast he'll hear
about this present before he actually
gets it which is
the scent of uh verbal agreement it's
just like an air freshener
um i got sam uh sports chips
sports chips yeah you should take a look
nick yeah you'll like oh dude
yeah they just love sports lingos all
over it it's just
run-on sentences about sports for the
whole label
yeah you can actually buy anything in
the grocery store or most of it
um like they had a robot milk which is
just sand
uh i got i got ivy some gum um which is
a doomed expedition
um like arctic madness and it's just
about like the packaging is just like an
arctic expedition that's failing and
they're
cannibalizing each other and that's the
how cold the gum is
[Laughter]
um so there's a bunch of like really
cool stuff you know you stand in those
shelves and you're picking all these
things out and looking at them and then
like different parts of the store like
you open a freezer and there's a tunnel
and then you walk to the tunnel and like
things shift and you find yourself in
this like alternate like dimension which
is this entire back part of this place
which is all these different cool
experiences
um like some really cool 3d projection
stuff happening in one room
a bunch of really crazy light
installations and they have like like
music machines where you can like play
beats with other people
and like change the visualizers based on
how you're mixing the music like there's
a whole bunch of like
little rooms with all these different
effectively art installations it's it's
basically a mini burning man i haven't
been to burning man but
i understand that apparently like a lot
of artists working on this are people
that make stuff for burning man
uh and you can just spend hours there
like playing with all these things it's
not it wasn't too crowded when i went
there like there's definitely people
there but like
do you go as like a a group or you just
you just
wander yeah you just wander it's like
yeah it's like a chuck e cheese's for
adults
yeah so i highly recommend anybody who
goes to vegas go check out omega mart
totally worth it um it's a ton of fun
and a bunch of really cool trippy things
maybe we can uh work that into our nab
trip
yeah yeah actually still not a bad idea
yeah if we do go to nab
cause that's the last time i was at
vegas was for anybody in 2019 gosh
yeah still gonna do that i think i think
it's something
in the fall yeah
all right gotta go network with the
youtube people
yeah the industry with the industry yeah
a lot has changed like in the
it has furious we went like when we went
in 2019 we did karaoke with people and
like the ceo of max on
and like you know we're just all a bunch
of nerds singing songs
and like now look at us now we're rock
stars now we're all rock stars including
especially people yeah
quite the opposite i feel like the world
has shifted in a way that has like
elevated
a lot of the uh the people working in
that industry that you know we're a part
of
um to be a lot more like publicly
visible and a lot more like impactful on
culture and all that
so that's interesting and i wonder how
it's going to shape nab when we go back
i think yeah christian just mentioned
astutely that react was not a thing last
time we went to nab
and then we were like just joking around
about the prospect about like
bringing the green couch out there yeah
yeah episode would be pretty sweet that
would be pretty cool yeah no i know it's
a
it's a big deal wait did i i mentioned
it yesterday the thing with neil
blanchamp oh oh yeah your friend neil my
friend neil
so so what is that because neon you know
you know neil have you met neil
uh my friend i saw this one
yeah yeah no no like because he's making
a movie and
he wanted he reached out yeah too he
makes movies do
something but yeah we're gonna try and
get him on the show soon
could he be more nonchalant about this
it's the coolest thing ever it's so cool
i'm so afraid of when he comes here
if this works out that like it's just
gonna be madness
it's just gonna be crazy like i forget
how to everyone's gonna be like doing
wacky things the ren's gonna be like
trying to like
dangle from stuff you know like it's
just gonna be like
it's just people are gonna like lose
their minds because
it's just like oh my god suddenly we're
gonna have like a full crew lighting
react everyone's gonna want to be the
show and how they can set up c-stands
no we only need like two people don't
worry
we might actually have to have a live
studio audience for that i mean i was
gonna
i was saying no reserving that for
jackie coming in you know because
everyone's
what about this thing or like yellow
questions and we can film them reacting
to the reactions
oh man we'll just put a mirror next to
the couch
oh yeah so he can watch himself as he
really no no you just we pan down to the
mirror to see
like random faces see if you're doing a
good job
yeah the react episodes with guests are
always the most intimidating
because like a lot of like now we're
winging it a lot of the times but like
you know we're working
off of our collective knowledge which
isn't always correct but thankfully in
editing you can catch some of these
things but when you have like a guest on
the couch next to you it's like
i get very timid about making like
concrete statements about how things are
done
statements yeah what's the most nervous
you've been
with any guest hmm
probably matt aiken yeah from wida it's
just like oh my god this guy is
like i am a poser next this dude
you know he was pretty legit man he
might find out if i say anything
so i'll just keep my mouth shut yeah
yeah it's pretty cool we're we're slowly
working our way up
jackie chan yeah we are we got scott
adkins of course he's close
scott atkins was awesome i know you guys
talked about this a little bit last time
but
that was a cool one to have that was
really cool i didn't know he'd fought
jackie
like twice or three times or whatever it
is yeah
that's gonna be a really good one what
did they have beef or something
no yeah yeah you just saw him he's like
you
come here no uh he when he was starting
out as a stuntman i guess he got to
fight him in the medallion
and then i forget the other movie he was
in he didn't really talk about
any others yeah jackie but i mean
they're just pretty straightforward
fights it sounded like yeah definitely i
need to reach out to him uh because
we talked about potentially doing like
an effect for his next movie and i'd
love to do like
some cool set piece effect for him yeah
yeah he has a cool thing going he is
able to like produce
and star in his own movies yeah like
that's kind of the dream i feel like
yeah yeah honestly steven's a goal yeah
honestly
and like make that money overseas too
like overseas yeah man but bounty
dude i'm surprised steven seagal still
makes movies
like they're so precious they're so
janky and weird
and strange we should definitely do some
stuntman react to something i saw
some clips from one he did like i forget
was like military themed and it was like
legit
airsofters it was like literally like
air softers
playing like like at one of those like
war sets that are up north of here
and like everyone's wearing like the
funniest like airsoft gear and
they're like we're navy seals it's like
you know you're pretending to be navy
seals and like
this is this is like it felt like an
eight-year-old was like explaining
like like like what the airsoft game was
gonna be like
dude you know he like seems to make the
point of sitting down for like all the
scenes right
he doesn't like to stand oh i can tell
he always changes scenes to sit down he
just also hits the stuntman
dude he's like him and like nick cage is
like
one step above stephen sogal and that
like
he has such a career now of just like
starring in these movies where he's like
the biggest guy in the poster and then
he's there for like three scenes sitting
down
yeah his recent ones are like weird
movies though which is
yeah you know it's like it's definitely
an artistic
like motive for for making these things
unlike steven seagal which is just like
trying to uphold his title as action
hero dude
well nick cage had some tax troubles so
that's why he ended up doing a lot of
movies oh really
yeah because he's got he had to pay off
the tax bill he almost pulled the wesley
snipes
well i was watching blade this weekend
and it's really weird that
wesley snipes went to jail for not
paying his taxes
it's like really you put blade in jail
that's where he's most dangerous because
he didn't pay his taxes i mean yeah make
him pay his taxes but you put him in
jail
how's that going to help anything go to
jail
that's what they say they catch you and
they're like go to jail now
the funny thing is like i can see how it
happens please
like if anybody's ever done 1099 work
like you get paid like oh cool
and you got to spend the money and then
like a year passes and then it's like
okay now you owe us
40 of that and you're like oh i didn't
know that was going to happen
i do not have 40 percent of the you know
whatever
million dollars he paid me 400 000
to give you for taxes like you know
that's a lot of money with wesley yeah i
mean
you can kind of see it i guess but to be
fair you should also maybe
maybe figure some of that stuff out
maybe yeah yeah just maybe have an
account
save some of it business advisor it's so
funny you're like you got all that money
and you're like man what should i buy
i should just start buying stuff
everything you spend all the money
and then this car is kind of expensive
but i guess i have the money
yeah i mean honestly it's that easy i
don't know how much he got paid for
blade i doubt it was more than a million
dollars you know
but he'd probably look up with his tax
evasion bill how many have crushed the
numbers for us
yeah crunch the numbers i wonder if the
warden of the prison where he was
staying was like
felt either really badass or really
scared like yeah
i got this this is like a scene where
he's trapped in jail he's gonna break
free
i've seen this before
and they're usually like in solitary or
something
that's so jacked up because it's like
you can't be with the commoners
don't push him with the commoners this
is a movie star
separate him the tower of london
take him to the gallows
we'll be placing you in this the third
story cell
away from the castle the tallest tallest
cell away from the commoners
just imagining wesley snipes up there in
the trench coat
getting walked all the way up the
stairwell
so apparently wesley snipes was a little
deeper in it
he anticipated so from 1999 to 2004 so
five years he made about 40 million
dollars and paid zero taxes and owed
23.5 million
he's like i'll pay 840 000. and they're
like
how about you go to jail for three years
one tank's worth wow three years
yeah in the tall tower so he actually
spent three years in prison
mm-hmm wow well it was like a minimum
security like
that's like a good fella's present that
isn't that like
of all the things celebrities can go to
jail for that's the one you can really
bounce back from
no questions asked right yeah you're not
like
oh you beat someone up oh you abused
someone oh you heard you know it's like
no you just didn't pay your taxes so
you're still a good guy in my books
you know like you can totally act you
can totally handle yourself on set
yeah you know you just just throw too
much money just keep the auditors
off off the set and we'll be good i mean
if you can
if you can bounce back from beating up
rihanna you can bounce back from not
paying your taxes
yeah i'm so chris brown just
keeps getting more famous yeah i think
that's really crappy
i think i think there's somebody said
like here can you guys separate the
artists from the art or are they tied in
your minds because they're definitely
linked in my minds i can't listen to
michael jackson anymore i know i don't
do r kelly
yeah it's such a weird that's the that
is the deepest
question that i think exists in our time
right now
and because i try and keep them separate
as much as possible
and i like because i'm like can you
enjoy something
that someone you don't like has made
or you did like when you first heard it
it made its
deep impression upon you and then you
realized that you don't like them
which is often the case especially well
with michael jackson
with any of the people who have been
canceled over the last
decade i mean michael has to be like the
hardest that's the hardest that just
even
like that happened yeah oh yeah yeah i
mean i think it's just it's just like
the separation of like the logic and
the emotional parts of your brain really
because like the emotional part
obviously still can enjoy everything
just fine i think but then the logic
part is where you're like oh
you know you stop listening to the song
and start hearing the
cries of young children
you know and that's that's where you're
like
i draw the line there yeah
it's i guess it depends i don't know
i've
i've probably not listened to michael
jackson since willingly
yeah i don't actually seek him out yeah
i can acknowledge that his music grooves
but like
i can give up michael jackson's music
for the sake of not like supporting a
man who
slept with children and for anybody who
in the comments were like well that's
not true it's like
watch that hbo documentary but then it
gets deeper it definitely happened but
yeah
it goes deeper and deeper and deeper and
you're like what was it his fault or was
he like raised in a twisted
doesn't it that one that one's like no
no no no
see and that's the thing you can't skip
generations to blame stuff
you know super fans justify that stuff
just like that all the time
it's pretty pretty scary and especially
in the film industry
i mean it's happened a million times
yeah
but that's that's it i do think people
also need to be able to forgive when
somebody changes like we need to always
make room for people to change
and become better people we can't just
hold somebody to like if somebody does
something bad and you will
never ever forgive them and you always
hold them to that well then you just
that's spiteful vengeance that's not
rehabilitation
you know like i maybe there's lines that
you know it's like oops i actually
i actually blew up this airplane things
i won't do it again i promise
like you know maybe those lines that you
uh you can cross
can't come back from but it was getting
bad they'd like bring up
super old tweets from yeah celebrities
and they'll be like oh you can't host
this like grammy show like
10 years later and you're like i'm not
the same person i probably didn't even
mean that
and you were like no you're cancelled i
honestly think yeah
but you guys are playing michael jackson
okay
that's a good point though i mean people
cancel people over tweet
maybe that's too far i don't know i
think
just don't use twitter you'll be fine it
also depends on the art i think too
like if it's a film and it's like say
the director or writer of a film that
gets cancelled
well there's a lot more people who have
artistic say in that film
right i mean yeah see that's the other
thing there too which is like
it's like literally like like apple news
pushes me like articles and sometimes
it's like
10 actors who turns out they're horrible
people
and it's just like all the best
filmmakers and actors and you're like
alfred hitchcock was a horrible person
like whoa okay
it's like this is like everyone like
right now
hollywood i mean yeah but no you're
right yeah that's the thing i think it's
just like that it's that group mentality
a little bit of like
no there's like plenty of great people
who put a lot of work into this too
also there's a difference between like
being an [ __ ] and being like an evil
person
like we don't get mad at drill sergeants
from being [ __ ]
sometimes you have to be a little bit of
an [ __ ] to get stuff done it's okay
they hurt your feelings big deal
they're an [ __ ] get over it but like
that's different from like oh they
abused you like you know
there's definitely lines that you can
cross but i
i don't feel upset if i found out like
that a director was addicted to people
on set
you know as long as the knowledge just
just emboldens you
as long as they're not like being
abusive you know like i think there's
different
definitely different like lines to cross
yeah it's like most people know that
that director
is an [ __ ] it's like don't if you you
know like everyone
on set in productions everyone knows
everyone talks about like the horror
stories that happen
and you willfully go on that set and
you're like no they're not going to be
and then they're an [ __ ] it's like
well you knew that
going in also though like there's a lot
of pressure on set i'm not trying to
justify
like straight abuse but like if you're a
director on a million dollar feature or
an actor like christian bale and the
whole sound
guy yeah blow up he had every right to
blow a hundred percent
he had not only every right he was in
the right yeah
cruz yelling at the crew about the masks
and stuff he had every right because
he's funding that film
you know he's producing it you've got a
lot of pressure on your shoulders and
like it all boils down to that one day
you probably haven't slept at all
you i mean dude i can't imagine what
being you actually on anyone
on set when you filmed a movie
we had like 12 people
no no they're all volunteering their
time damn it put the light over here i
was probably
too nice at some points honestly and
could have gotten maybe a couple more
takes it's like
maybe that's what makes [ __ ]
directors because they were too
complacent and didn't say enough maybe
and they saw what they could have done
and then you know i'm putting my
footprint on time but more like the way
the script i don't know okay no
no no no can you maybe say the words are
in the script oh you don't want to i
guess it's okay
do you want to be on the scene today oh
okay
yeah that's fine
no i mean i think there's a lot of
things that
the paparazzi and tabloids don't
obviously want to
acknowledge yes
rescue everything
i totally get holding people to a higher
standard
sometimes but it's like okay if that
person wasn't famous you wouldn't be
saying the same
thing like normal people across the
globe act a certain way but then once a
famous person
does it it's just chaos it's like
they're a normal person
they're normal or like when justin
bieber say something weird
and justin bieber is a good example
because whole like he's actually like
really
every time i've seen him like talk to
paparazzi he's been very like
nice until he's not because they are
straight up
to the edge he's like this is a human
being who you guys are just
terrorizing in the streets i haven't
seen the britney spears documentary but
that's like the
vibe i get from everyone i hear everyone
i heard about who saw it
and part of me is just like everybody
that goes out and buys those magazines
they're supporting that
they probably feel like they're
disconnected from it but no that's you
are
part of that person that's you know
torturing this person to get pictures
pretty gross yeah yeah i have this
philosophy that like that it's not
necessarily good and bad people
it's where everybody's good 90 of the
time they're an [ __ ] 10
of the time and just depends on what
time of the day you know did you happen
to catch them when they rolled that one
out of 10 when they're the [ __ ] or
did you happen to catch them when
they're
nice because i kind of feel like that's
really how everybody kind of functions
you know like [ __ ] drivers usually
it's just that
the person probably is not an [ __ ]
driver most of the time it's just on
that one time in the day that you pass
them that's when they're being the
[ __ ] driver
yeah i mean that's what driving in la is
like too i get so frustrated driving to
work i'm like everyone's an [ __ ]
driver it's like no there's just a lot
of people on the road
so that one in 10 chance is just
happening all the time
yeah yeah like i'll look back oh yeah i
was kind of dick in that one moment on
accident
and it's like oh maybe the other person
was a dick in that moment in accident
too
i don't know it'd be good for us to give
people the benefit of the doubt more
often
yeah and not just don't get so worked up
it's just never even worth it
and there's so many videos coming out of
people getting out of their car during
rush hour and like
hitting the person's car in front of
them because they're getting like super
angry
like well it's not worth it that person
might kill you yeah
hit their car at least don't stand in
front of it if you're gonna hit it
i had a a moment of
like extreme confrontation on the road
like three mornings ago
extreme cause like three years ago yeah
i think it was like thursday or friday
um i was heading to work
and a guy tried to merge into me
like didn't see that he was about to
merge into me and i could see his car
creeping over
so i like start honking like
i'm like come on what are you doing
they're after me no but like and
he was one of those la drivers that you
see all the time where
obviously never signals probably doesn't
look where he's going just expects
people to get out of his way
which a lot of people do surprisingly
they're just like oh yeah i'm just gonna
drift over
and if you're there you get out of the
way
so i i'm in front of him
he tried to merge in and i was like me
and i like speed ahead so he's behind me
and he's trying every car he's trying to
like get off to the side
and like there's like a car here so he
can't go off to the side and like
i was like no dude i'm not going to
speed up for you
to let you buy and he
got really pissed that he couldn't get
by me
and also probably because i like honked
at him like oh sorry dude yeah
god forbid it's like a kia soul honk to
it's like me
the nicest yeah it's honestly like
yeah it's literally like beaker from the
muppets
and he was riding my tail super
aggressive and i i
finally did merge over and he like
merges right behind me
like he's like i'm on you and so i'm
like [ __ ] so i get over one more time
and he went and i'm like okay this guy's
like
following me i want to be like past his
exit at this point because he was like
maybe so but like after a couple merges
and he's like right on my
my tail i was like he's like pissed at
me he's following me
so like i'm right on the seventh street
right before the exit
and i like pull this like need for speed
maneuver like cut like three lanes
again i'm the [ __ ] probably but like
i lost him and this guy
so right on the seventh street exit on
the 101
there's like a shoulder where there's
like those barrels of water
he freaking skids to a stop like almost
hitting the barrels oh really
i cut across and he tried to follow me
but he couldn't quite make it wow
and i left him i i looked over and his
car is like
and there's like traffic piling up
behind them and [ __ ] like wow
legit almost like what in that big dude
oh my gosh and i was like heart was
pounding i'm like
the tail though i lost i don't know if i
would have gotten like shot or something
just on my way to work if you'd like
caught up to me or what would have
happened
the golf golf thing golfing
the golf
that'll teach you that is really
stressful dude it was like
so so unnecessary it's like dude you
could have also just looked over your
shoulder
where you were merging but oh no you
know i just kind of did something like
that
i was about i park in front of them
every single day
and the the white van was behind me i
didn't even see them because i'm
i'm chill when i drive now because i was
my like blood pressure
it starts getting up oh me too and so i
start to go into my normal
spot
like that and like cuts me off and like
horizontally parks in two spots
and i almost hit the van because it was
my right of way
i was going to their spot and i was just
like like that but then he gets out of
the car and he's like you can park in
that one
like the other spot and i was like okay
you almost caused an
accident on hunter street because you
just feel entitled
and it was weird but i almost crashed
into the
man that would have been a whole crew
cuts episode i know
daniel would have been like yeah
[Laughter]
oh my gosh i really admire daniel's
persistence i know the vlogs
i always try to make time for him when
he needs to film with me even if it's
like interrupting everything else
it's just like i yeah well cause like
it's like that's like almost that's
basically what he would do
yeah i think he would make the attempt
you would ask and like can i
can i film this you have to if you're
gonna try to tell stories like even the
most unproductive days
as long as i filmed with daniel i feel
like i got something
yeah so good sometimes it seems like the
most you're like there's
no way you're going to get a story out
of this crew cut episode drops
wow you're like this is the best story
ever yeah
and everyone in the comments like this
was so meaningful
we had no idea what was happening
yeah that's real skill right there in
terms of editing stories using the
motion out of those everyday moments
or like oh like save those little he'll
save scenes sometimes for like months
oh yeah and then he'll wait till there's
a perfect thing that it can support or
that there's a you know
you can tie it together for some
overarching story yeah so
it's like because it's all fabricated
and like but it's true but it's 100
fabricated at the same time where it's
like
because he's been filming all this stuff
with the green screen
unreal stuff that i've been doing over
the last few months and he's like he
started he came to nico
to film a bit with it and me yesterday
and i'm like like damn dude
you know like you you've been like this
whole thing there's like a whole story
here and he's like yeah
like and this is what i need this is
what i want you to say for it and like
it's like want me to say that it's like
okay and then i say i'm like
yeah that was the truth i didn't even
know that like that was like the
fitting part of this story i'm like
we're too busy to think in that like
kind of like storytelling like emotional
like i don't know there's something very
like
idyllic almost about it it's like core
truths of like
and like it's always very positive like
which i love but i've noticed that
sometimes
we're not in the mind state to exactly
give that and that's where his like
persistence
like you were saying because like
and like i know me like sometimes
he'll like try to interview me and like
i've never been like super like outward
with my emotions towards people
and so it's still kind of weird
sometimes like being interviewed about
someone when i'm sitting right next to
them
you know so like i've been getting
hopefully better about it
it's like well i should be able to say
positive things about my coworkers in
front of them like you know even though
like
maybe it's not what i do every day like
you know so it's been a learning
experience for sure
um externalizing that stuff
for in such like a funny literal way you
know
so i've never seen someone just never
take no for an answer
as professionally as he does it's great
because people be like no and then
people like
well
[Laughter]
you know it's gonna be a really good
episode the mics are you're already
wearing them
and yeah when did you do this
[Laughter]
the drone and daniel immediately goes
like that and it was like i don't want
to do this and he's like
so i crashed the drone
that's such a good episode dude the
moment we're like wren's goofing around
and like i'm doing my first like box
jump into the pad
and you're like wren can you cut it out
everyone's like oh and you see
it like that moment was captured so well
it encompassed everything because ryan
was talking like i don't want to
distract from
nico's big moment but i lost my drone
and i need help getting it back
[Laughter]
then he calls on his older brother
solomon yes to uh
go get it and solomon just like pulls a
move and jumps on the roof and grabs it
he's like whoa yeah solomon was such a
pro
the uh these comments pointed out like
when i was jumping off the ladder that
he'd reach up and cover like the the
knuckle on the top of the ladder so i
wouldn't smack my head onto it
it's like yeah those little touches
that's like that's what being a
professional stuntman stunt coordinator
stunt rigger is all about is like that
attention to detail and safety
cause you can't get lacks about those
little things because you're doing it
every day
and if you're rolling throwing a hundred
sided dice and you hit that one
and you know that's an injury it's like
and you're gonna be rolling the dice
five times a day
every day for like 10 years in a row
like you're gonna hit one at some point
so you gotta always take those little
steps and be safe
yeah people will die yeah i had
no idea wren was filming a story with
daniel for that
so i was like i watched that moment back
and i was like
oh i totally deflated this moment no i
was just like stop that
i mean you made the right call like that
was definitely like the
the legit right call to make cause it's
like we are trying to focus and this is
like this is what we're doing here it's
this jump and like randy got to wait
and randy kind of knew that also but
that's almost what made it even better
yeah it was like perfect timing and then
nick got cancelled to being an [ __ ]
yes the paparazzi
wait i missed that part you got
cancelled no no no no
not yet anyway geez not you better stop
tweeting
you better stop making making movies i
do get worried about like delivering
too hot of a take on the podcast
sometimes and that's fine
what the heck yeah you're right don't
worry about it
i feel like i do feel like we're lucky
in that everyone who listens to this
podcast like the audience that watches
quarter stuff happens to be
an audience that's very like thoughtful
and
even-minded and honestly like we have a
pretty diverse i think array of opinions
and
what people enjoy in our audience so it
always like tends to lend itself towards
good discussion as opposed to like name
calling
which is awesome so hey you'll see this
podcast good on you
good on you for being a cool audience
member yeah yeah
the end and that's
the end wait what podcast what it is
it is i guess it is well i mean that's
like what
what a great note it is
who's watching this is super cool you
should take that to heart
seriously though i do really enjoy like
the in-depth like comments that will
happen especially like
when we talk about something we don't
know a ton about and like someone's like
well actually i do this professionally
and like and there's like usually a
really like
helpful kind like you know hey you're
you didn't know about this but let me
enlighten you kind of approach
yeah wink wink link wink
[Laughter]
oh wait i can't wait to hear everything
it's like i'm a realtor in
san francisco i can tell you about the
problems here
we talked about san francisco for like a
solid 30 minutes those were the
worst land picks of the month
uh first biomes a swamp is not a trench
excuse me
it's called a fjord actually yeah
landscapes clearly and uh it is 900
including sales tax i'm a professional
thing-taker
what are you guys what are you going to
do with your 900 bucks after this
podcast
honestly razors are expensive oh razors
razors
like excuse me like the laptops the
scooters
i'm a i'm a mac girl until i've done
that
like shaving razors yeah i'd stop
shaving
10 years ago
yeah cool so that's what i'm gonna get
some socks some haynes
now that socks are free oh and i'm gonna
get pro controllers for everyone in the
studio call
oh if if i can find a switch i'll get
you okay thanks
you guys are thinking about our smash
brothers tournament soon
yeah yeah it's almost time i think we
gotta do duo's before that
i know my character i think if we do it
would have to be a separate tournament i
think oh definitely a separate
tournament and christian's my teammate
right
yep me and christian king k rool and
ganondorf well dean and myself will be
the teammates because we have a winning
combination
one person serves the sausages yes one
if you're doing duos well see nick was
saying him but he was like you don't
need it i've gotten way better
than this since our video since the one
that we did
[Laughter]
no i think if we run that video back you
were like okay i don't get why people
hate people
i don't know i haven't really played
with chase but i feel like chase would
be like
chase is a sleeper people don't know but
chase is legit good at smash brothers
if i had a duo just waits in the shadows
yeah he's been training and waiting
i feel like carmichael's been doing the
same oh did he get a switch
i think he has one or bottled water no i
need to get one are we gonna
are we fading out on this one yeah we're
gonna get on this podcast play us out
sam
under the no no we could just keep
talking and the volume we'll get
i still want to hear jordan's pick would
be who would be your teammate me and
christian do pretty well together
christian's my teammate i know you
should play each other solos
okay and then dana sam's teammate matt
interest yeah we both like to use our
little lassos to make things happen
me and daniel can be teammates yeah how
about that yeah there you go
or jake you'll forfeit
you'll just be like no we refused to go
back to work we are boycotting
and you guys have to come up with a real
good reason the boycott that can trend
yeah all right all right thanks for
listening everybody thanks we'll see you
guys in the next girls